I solved that with recursion, and you solved it in BQN with generating the permutation of the functions plus and multiply, and then applying that to the list of numbers. Inverse of indices. That is a BQN idiom for basically giving you the histogram of a list of numbers. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 214 recorded on December 16th, 2024. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Ben, we discuss the different algorithmic approaches to solving advent of code problems in different programming languages. Anyways, how's it going? We're getting close to the holiday season. Yeah, Christmas is really coming up fast. Yeah, it's incredible that we're already halfway through december um oh my god nine days away yeah i didn't yeah i didn't even realize it's really coming up i did i did all
我用递归解决了那个问题，而你用 BQN 通过生成加法和乘法函数的排列，然后将其应用于数字列表来解决它。索引的逆运算。这是 BQN 的一个惯用法，基本上可以为你提供数字列表的直方图。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 214 期，录制于 2024 年 12 月 16 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 将讨论在不同编程语言中解决 Advent of Code 问题的不同算法方法。总之，最近怎么样？我们快到假期了。是的，圣诞节真的很快就要到了。是的，真不敢相信已经到十二月中旬了，哦天哪，还有九天，是的，我甚至没意识到，真的快到了，我昨天把礼物都包好了，所以那件事完成了，我立了圣诞树，做了圣诞装饰，哦是的，我想你过着那种有房有地、能放得下圣诞树的人的生活，是的，我想是这样。我还没到人生的那个阶段，餐桌上放着一棵小小的圣诞树。酷。嗯，你的背景看起来很棒。嗯，是的，多亏了谷歌和他们的虚拟，我不知道，严格来说，这是增强现实。
my present wrapping yesterday so that was done uh i put up my tree did christmas decorations oh yeah you i guess yeah you're living the life of uh someone who owns a place and can fit a tree yeah i suppose so. I haven't hit that stage of my life yet where there's technically a tiny Christmas tree sitting on the dining table. Cool. Well, your background looks great. Well, yes, thanks to Google and their virtual, I don't know, technically, this is an augmented reality.
你会怎么称呼这个？这只是一个虚拟背景。是的，我想是这样。是的。总之，最近怎么样？我们已经有几周没聊天了。很好。是的。
What would you call this? It's just a virtual background. Yeah, I suppose. Yeah. Anyways, how have things been? It's been a couple of weeks since we chatted. Good. Yeah.
没什么特别要说的。我想利用这段时间问你一些关于 APL 和 AOC 的问题。是的。因为我觉得这可能很有趣，我想这就是我们最初为敏锐的听众预留的话题，我想我们在两部分棋盘游戏那一集的结尾提到过，我们打算聊聊 APL，你作为一名 C++ 开发人员问我一些问题，我们没能聊到那个，但现在我们回来了，你知道我们还没跑题，而且现在我们正处于
Nothing much to report. I wanted to spend this time to ask you some questions about APL, about AOC. Yeah. Because I thought that might be interesting i think that's we were we were initially that was the topic that we had slotted for the astute listener i think we referenced it at the end of the two-part board games episode that we were intending to uh have a conversation about apl where you as a c++ dev asked me some questions we we failed to talk about that but now we're back with uh you know we haven't been derailed yet and now that we're in
十二月中旬，我们可能会结合一些 Advent of Code 的内容，所以是的，我看过你的 Advent of Code 代码报告视频，我想目前为止所有的我都看了，我看到了我们现在的进度，第 16 天，你可能有 10 个视频，我想也许 9 到 10 个左右，差不多吧，我已经完成了 14 天，我读了第 15 天，只是这两天太忙了，我做了第 1 到 6 或 7 天，然后跳到了第 10 天，一旦我有更多时间，你知道还有几个假期要来，所以我计划做更多视频，但确实有接近 10 个，而且我都是用 BQN 做的，如果你愿意的话，那是 APL 2.0，对，是的，所以我做了一些，我完成了前三天的 Advent of Code，还有第 7 天和第 11 天。
the middle of december we might tie in some advent of code uh stuff as it goes so yeah so i've i've watched your advent of code uh code report videos uh i think all of them up to this point um i've reached our what we're up to day 16 or 16 today and you have probably 10 videos i think maybe 9 10 something like that something like that i have finished all of 14 days i read day 15 and just I've been super busy the last couple days and I've made I think it was day one through six or seven then I skipped to day 10 and once I have some more you know there's a couple holidays coming off so I plan to make some more videos but there is yeah close to upwards of 10 I think and I'm doing them all in bqn which is apl 2.0 if you want right right um so i've been doing a few of them i've done the first three event of codes and days and uh i did day 7 and i did day 11
而且我注意到，从你往年的 Advent of Code 来看，前几天通常很容易。我认为前几天很适合做 10 分钟的视频，对吧？特别是 Advent of Code，早期的一些问题在 10 分钟内从算法上是可以解释清楚的，对吧？你的 BQN 视频在某种程度上反映了这一点。所以我很想问你，我注意到在第 10 天你使用了递归，在……
and uh i've been noticing and also from previous years of you you know, Advent of Code, the first days are generally easy. And I think the first days lend themselves to 10-minute videos, right? And in particular with Advent of Code, some of the early ones are fairly algorithmically explainable in 10 minutes, right? And your BQN videos reflect that somewhat. So I wanted to ask you like i so i noticed um a couple of the days um on day on day 10 you use recursion on day you know like
随着 Advent of Code 的深入，我所认为的 BQN 或 APL，我认为它是一种非常擅长高度数学化事物的语言，比如任意维度的数组、过滤、归约等等。阅读 Advent of Code 中的一些问题，其中几个我用我的方法解决了，我往年做这个主要是为了学习语言，比如我用 Haskell 做过，我用 Awk 做过，这些天我认为解决 Advent of Code 的最好方法是每天找到适合这项工作的工具。对。所以有几天，比如早期的一天，就像，哦，完全是。
as we get later on in advent of code what what i think of as BQN or APL, I think of it as a language that is really good at highly mathematical things like arrays of any dimension, just filtering, reducing, all that kind of stuff. And reading through some of these problems in Advent of Code, a couple of them I solved in my my approach to event of code i have in previous years done it to ostensibly to learn languages like when you're i did it in haskell um when you're i did it in orc these days i think the best approach to event of code is to for each day find the language that fits the find the tool that fits the job. Right. So there are a couple of days, like one of the early days was like, Oh, totally.
我在命令行里用一行代码解决了。我想我发给你了。大概是第三天左右。嗯，后来的一天，是哪一天来着，
I did it on the command line in, in a one liner. I think I sent you that. It was like three or so. Um, one of the later days, uh, which one was,
哦，就是那一天，你必须……我想是第七天，
Oh, the, the, the day where you had to, uh, it was day seven, I think, um,
你有一个数字和一堆数字，你可以在它们之间放入加号或乘号来组成，问题是对于每一行数字，你能通过在任何位置用加号和乘号组合其他数字来得到总和吗？哦是的，我用递归解决了，而你用 BQN 通过生成加法和乘法函数的排列，然后将其应用于数字列表来解决它。那很好。我很想知道你第 11 天是怎么做的，
where you had a number and, and a bunch of numbers that you could put plus or multiply in between them to make and and the question was for every line of numbers can you can you make the sum oh yeah by combining the others with plus and multiply in any of the places i solved that with recursion and you solved it in BQN with generating the permutation of the functions plus and multiply, and then applying that to the list of numbers. That was fine. I'm interested to know what you did for day 11,
因为第 11 天我用了 Python，第 11 天的关键是动态规划，即记忆化其中一个函数。在 Python 中，这超级简单。你只需要加一个装饰器，这就是为什么我认为 Python 是那天的好工具。所以我很想知道你是否用 BQN 解决了第 11 天，以及你是怎么做的。让我回忆一下，幸运的是我有 VS Code 实例，所以我可以直接输入第 11 天，所以这是……哦是的，这就是那个……这里也一样，它有点像那种
because day 11, I used Python, and the key to day 11 was dynamic programming, was memorizing one of the functions. And in Python, that is super simple. You just put a decorator up, which is why I thought Python was a good tool for that day. So I'm interested if you've tackled day 11 in BQN and what you did for that. So let me refresh my memory luckily i have the vs code instance so i can just type day 11 so this was oh yeah this was the one where it up as well here it's kind of one of those like
类似于……是考拉兹猜想吗？我可能完全说错了，就是如果是偶数就除以 2，如果是奇数就乘以 3 加 1 之类的，嗯，我不能……好吧，这是一种一维的有限自动机，对吧？它是一个有限自动机，你观察单元格中的值并做一些事情，其中一件你可以做的事情是把单元格一分为二，所以它变成了这种指数级增长的东西，是的，然后是 A 部分和 B 部分，所以我认为规则是——我只是通过看代码来做——如果你给出一个初始数字列表，我想有三种不同的规则。我正在阅读。我正在为 BQN 代码进行翻译。
it's similar to is it the collapse conjecture i might be totally off where it's like if it's even you divide by two if it's odd you multiply by three and add one or something like that uh i can't yeah well it's a sort of a finite automata in one dimension right it's a finite automaton where you look at the value in the cell and you do something and one of the things you can do is split the cell in two and so it becomes this exponentially growing thing yes yeah and then parts a and b and so i think the rules and i'm doing this just by looking at the code is that if your num so you're get you you're given an initial list of numbers and there's i think I think, three different rules. And I'm just reading. I'm translating for BQN code.
所以这是对我阅读 BQN 代码难易程度的测试。是的。实际上，我不确定我是否可以共享屏幕，希望我们不会完全破坏听众的体验。但是，你知道。好的。如果我能做到的话。所以当涉及到阅读 BQN 和 APL 时，我非常像我们的一位普通听众，我读过 Iverson 关于它的论文，但是你知道，Connor 在这里
So this is a test of how easy is it for me to read BQN code. Yeah. And I can actually, I'm not sure if, I can share my screen, and we will hopefully not completely destroy the listener's ability. But, you know. Okay. If I get to. So I am very much like probably one of our regular listeners when it comes to reading bqn and apl i i've read iverson's paper on it um but you know connor here has
写过一篇关于组合子的硕士论文，而且我从来没有真正使用过 APL 或 BQN 来解决 Advent of Code 问题。我读过 Raymond Smolian 的书，仅此而已。所以请解释一下。是的。所以我们会尽力不让 Ben 和听众迷失。所以我认为希望我们在第一个问题上能成功，因为你可以在任何时候打断我。但如果我们让听众迷失了，我们深表歉意，所以我的意思是，我们马上要讲的三条规则，都在
written a master's thesis about about combinators and uh the last time i have never used APL or BQN even really to solve an Advent of Code problem. I've read Raymond Smolian's book and that's it. So please explain. Yes. So we'll do our best to not lose both Ben and the listener here. So I think hopefully we'll be successful on the first one because you can just stop me at any point. But if we lose the listener we do apologize so i mean there's three rules that we're going to walk through in a sec which is all in
这个 blink 函数里，我通常会跳过每个问题的前三四段，因为它们对于解决问题来说是不必要的，但它与每次闪烁时这个数字列表会发生变化有关。A 部分只是，我想，25 次闪烁后的数字之和是多少？第二个是 75 次闪烁后。对。我们会谈到为什么它变得棘手，因为基本上你的列表大小会爆炸。是的。以典型的 Advent of Code 风格，我们都看过 Eric 的主题演讲。
this blink function i typically skip the first three or four paragraphs of every problem because it's it's it's unessential inessential to solving the problem but it had to do with like every time you blink this list of numbers is going to morph. And part A is just, I think, is it what's the sum of the numbers after 25 blinks? And the second one is after 75 blinks. Right. And we'll come to why it becomes tricky because basically the size of your list is going to explode. Yeah. In typical Advent of Code style, we've both seen Eric's keynote.
他去年在 CP North 做过一次主题演讲，我想他在几个会议上都做过同样的主题演讲，谈论 Advent of Code。非常值得一看。他说的其中一件事是，Advent of Code 往往包含这些指数级风格的问题，因为有趣的一点是，你不想制造一个只有 C++ 程序员能解决而 Python 程序员不能解决的问题，对吧？所以语言不会，你知道，做这些指数级第二部分的成本太高了，
He gave a keynote at CP North last year, and I think he's given that same keynote in a couple of conferences where he talks about Advent of Code. Very worth a watch. And one of the things he says is Advent of Code tends to contain these exponential-style problems because one of the interesting things is you don't want to make a problem where someone can solve it in C++ and not in Python, for instance, right? So the language doesn't, you know, the cost of doing these exponential part twos is too big,
即使你使用的是编译语言，没有……好吧，我的意思是，这些天你可能拥有整个农场、整个云，你可以花很多钱来做。但它确实，我要说对于这个问题，即使在 BQN 中，你也不能暴力破解它。如果你认为你在暴力破解它，可能 BQN 内部有一些东西在为你工作，对吧？我之所以说有时是因为我认为，而且我对今年的 Advent of Code（2024 年，如果你在未来几年听这个的话）感到相当惊讶。我想只有一两个问题，我实际上不得不做些什么。这实际上是其中一个问题，我的第一个解决方案，我不能只是增加
even if you're using a compiled language without finding, well, I mean, these days you might have like a whole farm, a whole cloud, you could pay lots of money to do it. But it does, I'm going to say for this problem, even in BQN, like you can't brute force it. And if you think you're brute forcing it, probably that BQN internally has something which is working to your advantage, right? The reason I say sometimes is I think, and I've been rather surprised with this year's Avenue of Code, which is 2024, in case you're listening to this years in the future. I think only one or two of the problems, I actually had to do something. And this was actually one of the problems where my first solution, I couldn't just increase
数字或改变东西。就像字面上一样，我不记得是哪一天了。我想是那一天，你必须找到从 0 到 9 递增 1 的路径起点。我的解决方案中只有一个字符的差异。对。因为它只是，你能到达那里吗？有多少种不同的方式？而且我已经在去重了。
the number or change the thing. Like literally, I can't remember which day it was. I think it was the day where you had to find the number, the trail heads from zero to nine increasing by one. That was a single character difference in my solution. Right. Because it was just, can you get to it and how many different ways? And I was already deduplicating.
我已经在计算所有路径，然后只是观察位置，所以解决方案只是删除去重并计算你到达那里的方式，而在 APL 中去重是一个字符，所以我只是删除了它，或者是添加它，我感到很震惊，因为通常你期望的是，哦，我希望我做了这个，是移除它，是的，是的，为了和你谈话，爸爸，我昨晚看了你的代码报告视频。所以，是的，确实是。也许我们之后可以讨论反馈。好吧，其中一个里有个 bug，我们稍后会讲到。
I was already calculating all the paths and then just like looking at the position and so the solution was just delete the deduplication and count how many ways did you get there and and deduplicate as a single character in apl so i just deleted it was either adding it or deleting it and i was shocked because usually you expect like oh i hope i did this it was removing it yes yeah in preparation for talking to you, Dad, I watched your code report videos last night. So, yes, it was. Maybe we can get to feedback afterwards. Well, you have a bug in one of them, which we'll come to.
哦，好吧，这是一个 bug，嗯，我们留到以后再说。总之，我们在第 11 天，A 部分，B 部分，25 次迭代对比 75 次迭代。你得到一个数字列表，如果我能让这个工具提示消失的话。这里是规则。所以这个 blink 函数基本上就是执行这个动作的东西。所以它这里说如果它等于零。然后你只是，这基本上是一个三元表达式。对。
Oh, well, it's a bug that, well, we'll save that for later. So, anyways, we're on day 11, part A, part B, 25 iterations versus 75 iterations. And you're given a list of numbers, if I can get this tooltip to disappear. And here are the rules. So this blink function basically is going to be what performs this action. So it says here if it's equal to zero. And then you're just, this is basically a ternary expression. Yeah.
所以你有一个，你有一个 1，只是为了设置，你有一个一维数字数组，对吧？对于该数组中的每个数字、每个单元格，你都在执行此操作，它就像一个有限自动机，所以数组随着每次闪烁而改变，数组的每个单元格都会做一些改变，是的，所以如果它等于零，你就把数字变成 1，这是第一条规则，如果它……我……所以这读起来是如果 mod 2 等于 0，所以它能被 2 整除，嗯，你只是想……这上面写着什么？你想取……或者不……所以如果长度……我错过了这部分的第一部分，如果系统函数 repper 的长度，这意味着转换
So you've got a, you've got a one, just to set up, you've just this is basically a ternary expression yeah so you've got a you've got a one just to set up you've got a one dimensional array of numbers right and for each number each cell in that array you are doing this operation it's like a finite automaton that so the the array changes with every blink and each cell of the array does something to change yeah and so if it's equal to zero you change your number to one that's the first rule if it i and so what this reads is if mod two equals zero so it's divisible by two uh you just want to uh what does this say you want to take or no so it's if the length i missed out the first part of this if the length of the system function repper which means convert
这个为字符串，能被 0 整除，所以如果你有偶数个数字，如果它的十进制表示有偶数个数字，是的，那么你想做的是第二种操作，你想……我代码里写的是……我在这里做了一些冗余的工作，我把数字转换成了两次字符串。所以从技术上讲，我可以把它分配给一个局部变量，但对于这个目的，它并没有真正影响。所以你把它转换成字符串，然后切割它。切割意味着什么？
this to a string is divisible by zero so if you have an even number of digits if it's decimal representation has an even number of digits yeah then what you want to do this is the second uh operation is you want to what i have written in my code is uh i'm i'm doing sort of some redundant work here i'm converting it to a string twice So technically I could have assigned this to a local, but for the purpose of this, it didn't really matter. So you're converting it to a string and then you're cutting it. And what does a cut mean?
切割意味着基本上把它切成两半。所以我利用了 BQN 中一个非常美妙的东西，你给它一个形状，即 2。然后我实际上没有填入最终维度，这只是说给我一个两行的矩阵，带有正确的列数，这将分割它，所以你从一个秩为 1 的数组（也就是向量）变成了一个两行的矩阵，它基本上会在每一行中有两个数字，然后我调用了一个名为 parse float 的函数，它接收一个字符串，然后将其转换为整数。
A cut means to basically slice it in two. So I'm making use of a very beautiful thing in BQN where you give it a shape, which is a two. And then I'm not actually filling in the final dimension and this is just saying give me a two row matrix with the correct number of columns that will split that so you're going from a rank one array aka a vector to a matrix of two rows which is going to basically have the two digits in each row and then I'm calling a function called parse float, which takes a string and then converts that to an integer.
我是在逐行的基础上做这件事的。所以我基本上是把这个字符矩阵当作字符串处理每一行，然后把它转换回整数。所以这只是将一个偶数位数字转换为两个数字的一种非常可爱的方法。所以用英语说，你是在文本上把数字切成两半。
And I'm doing that on a row wise basis. So I'm basically taking this matrix of characters and treating each row as a string and then converting it back into an integer. So this is just a very cute way of converting a number with an even number of digits into two, uh, two numbers. So in, in English, you're, you're cutting the number in half textually.
所以 1234 变成了 12 和 34。对。例如。而且它非常好。事实上，你可以用系统 BQN 函数做得慢一点，它只是接收任何任意的 BQN 表达式并对其求值，但我记不清是不是这一天了，但其中一天我最终遇到了运行时问题，我通过查看其他人的解决方案发现，如果你知道你的表达式只是一个整数或浮点数字面量，使用这个 parse float 要快得多，因为它会比仅仅求值任何任意的 BQN 表达式要简单得多，所以条件 1 是 0
So 1,234 becomes 12 and 34. Yeah. For example. And it's quite nice. And in fact, actually, you can do this a little bit slower with the system BQN function, which just takes any arbitrary bqn expression and evaluates it but i can't remember if it was this day but one of the days i ended up running into like uh runtime problems and i discovered by looking at other folks solutions that if you know your expression is is just an integer or a float literal it's way faster to use this parse float because that's going to be uh much simpler simpler than evaluating just any arbitrary bqn expression anyway so condition one is zero
把它改成 1，条件 2 是偶数位数字，把它切成两半，条件 3 是 else 情况，所以没什么可检查的，你乘以 2024，这只是……好的，所以这三种情况你可以做三件事。而且是分割的那一个。是那个一个单元格变成两个，随着时间的推移，正如你所理解的，使数组呈指数级增长。对。
change it to one condition two even number of digits split it in half and condition number three which is just the else case so there's nothing to check for you multiply by 2024 which is just okay so there are three things you can do for those three cases. And it's the splitting one. It's the cutting the... It's the one cell becoming two that, as you can appreciate over time, makes the array grow and grow exponentially. Yeah.
对于 A 部分，我实际上认为我甚至不需要这个步骤函数。所以我有一个额外的步骤函数，它使用 blink。但对于 A 部分，我基本上只是用重复运算符调用了 blink，这是……我不知道你称它为什么，道德上、精神上等价，但它有点像没有索引的 for 循环，你只是传递给它一个函数，然后执行该函数那么多次，对吧？对。所以它就像 Haskell，这就像 Haskell 的 iterate 吗？或者它是通用的，我想如果它是的话，所以它就像它的扫描，如果你喜欢的话，重复运算符就像一个累加。
And for part A, I don't actually think I even needed this step function. So I have this extra step function, which uses blink. But for part A, I basically just called blink with the repeat operator which is uh i don't know if it's what do you call it morally spiritually equivalent but it's it's kind of like a for loop without the indices you just pass it a function and you perform that function that many times right Right. So it's like Haskell, is this like Haskell's iterate? Or it's the general, I think if it is, so it's like the scan of it, if you like, the repeat operator is like an accumulation.
但如果那被展开成一个扫描，它会是，你会得到 X，F(X)，F(F(X))，F(F(F(X)))，恰好重复给了你那个序列的末尾，所以你得到了 F(X)，F 应用于 X 25 次，迭代地，是的，扫描和重复之间肯定存在不对称，除非我会把这个更多地比作归约，因为扫描输出中间状态，这里的关键是你的函数只有一个输入，嗯，我认为它是 iota 的泛化，iota 是重复，函数是加 1，基本上你有一个起始状态和一个一元函数，它应用该一元函数
But if that were expanded out to a scan, it would be, you'd be getting X, F of X, F of F of X, F of F of F of of x just so happens that the repetition is giving you the end of that sequence so you're you're getting f of x apply f applied to x 25 times iteratively yes there is definitely a asymmetry between scan and repeat except i would compare this more to a reduction because scan outputs the intermediate state the key here is that there's only one input to your function um i think of it as the generalization of iota iota is repeat with the function being plus one right basically you have a start state and a unary function and it applies that unary function
n 次，在这种情况下是 25，对吧？而归约和扫描，它们在技术上不取新的状态，而是取一个新值并有一个二元运算，它们取它携带的状态加上新的信息，通常以列表或其他形式，但是的，非常类似于 Haskell，我永远记不住，有 iterate，还有另一个，它们都有些相似，但是的，所以无论如何，你迭代这个函数 25 次，你重复它，是的，这给了你 25 次闪烁后的数组，是的，你会看到这里有一堆我们称之为仪式的东西，比如这个 tack reduce。这是拼写 last 的双字符方式。这是因为我们必须为 B 部分对这个解决方案所做的修改。
n number of times in this case 25 right uh whereas like reductions and scans they technically take new not state but like they take a new value and have a binary operation where they're taking the state that it's carrying along plus the new information typically in the form of a list or something but yeah very similar to the haskell i can never remember there's iterate and then there's another one that are both somewhat similar but yeah so anyway you iterate this function 25 times you repeat it yeah that gives you the array after 25 blinks yeah and you'll you'll see that there's a bunch of what we'll call a ceremony around this, like this tack reduce. This is a two-character way of spelling last. And that's because of the modifications to this solution that we had to do for part B.
所以 A 部分简单得多。它只有一个 blink 函数，重复 25 次，把它们加起来，你就完成了，它没有这个额外的 tack reduction，这是……就像我说的，拼写 last 的双字符方式，因为对……因为 tack 是取右边的东西，完全正确，是的，所以如果你在数组上归约它，你得到最右边的东西，也就是最后一个，对于……在这种情况下，我们只有一个双元素数组。这是一种拼写 Haskell 中的 second，SND，甚至是 C++ 中 pair 的 dot second 的痛苦方式。
So part A was much simpler. It just had a blink function, repeat 25 times add those up you're done it didn't have this extra tack reduction which is uh like i said a two character way of spelling last because right so because tack is take the thing on the right exactly yeah and so if you reduce that over an array you get the thing on the far right which is the last thing for it and for uh in this case we just have a two-element array. It's a painful way of spelling like second, S-N-D in Haskell, or even dot second in C++ on your pair.
而且这实际上是我最大的抱怨之一。如果我必须列出关于 BQN 中数组语言的前十件事，我不认为它们中有任何一个有 last 原语。它们都有 first，但没有 last。而且我认为还有一堆其他原语被添加了，它们的使用频率远低于 last。而且你总是会结束，特别是当你构建分叉时，当它们对称时，它们是美丽的，你有一个用于 first 的单个字形，
And it's actually one of my largest complaints. If I had to make a list of the top ten things about array languages in BQN, I don't actually think any of them have a last primitive. They all have first, but they don't have last. And I think that there's a bunch of other primitives that have been added that are used way less frequently than last. And you always end up, especially when you're building up forks, which are things that are beautiful when they're symmetric, you have a single glyph for first,
然后是一个双字符字形，甚至不是字形，是一个双字符表达式，这真的是应用，就像这有点像个技巧，比如 tack reduction，你第一次看到这个时，就像，那是什么？因为它不是获取最后一个东西的直观方式，你可能想反转并取它的第一个东西，那是我刚开始用 APL 编程时拼写它的方式。这里有性能影响吗？是因为 first 是常数时间吗？但 TAC reduction 听起来是线性时间。但有没有可能有一个在常数时间内返回 last 的原语？
and then a two-character gly glyph not even glyph a two character expression that is really the application like this is kind of a trick like the tack reduction the first time you see this it's like what what is that because it's it's not the intuitive way to get the last thing you might want to reverse and take the first thing of that that was how i used to spell it when i started programming in APL. Is there a performance implication here? Is that like, because first is, you know, constant time. TAC reduction sounds like linear time. But would it be possible to have a primitive that returns last in constant time?
或者底层发生了什么让它……？是的，我知道的大多数（如果不是全部）数组实现都有针对此的惯用语识别。所以这是一个常数时间操作。但如果它没有惯用语识别，它将是线性的。而且它仍然比 first on reverse 更可取，因为那实际上会……因为那也在移动东西，是的。我想我实际上应该说 CAP 是惰性的。它内置了惰性求值。
Or does something happen in under the hood to make it? Yeah, most, if not all, the array implementations that I know of have an idiom recognition for this. So it's a constant time operation. But if it didn't have idiom recognition, it would be linear. And it still would be preferable to the first on reverse because that's actually going to... Because that's moving things around as well as, yeah. I think actually I should say that CAP is lazy. It has lazy evaluation built into it.
所以在这种情况下，如果你做一个 first reduce，它实际上会是最快的，因为它会执行某种类似于 C++ 2023 视图的视图转换。反转它，然后它只需要第一个，它就会在那里短路。所以可以说 CAP 实际上在没有命中识别的情况下具有常数时间。但要进入 B 部分，所做的修改，我实际上借用了这个。你可以看到我这个深受 J.H. Franklin（GitHub 用户名）的启发。因为我实际上不确定在这里该做什么。它有一个非常可爱的技巧，使用了我最喜欢的 BQN 惯用语之一，它基本上做了一个去重，并以数组等效的哈希映射或计数器集合的形式存储你当前的列表
So in that case, if you do a first reduce, it's actually going to be the fastest because it's going to perform some kind of view transformation similar to C++ 2023 views. Reverse it and then just it needs the first and it's going to short circuit right there. So arguably CAP actually has the constant time without hitting recognition. But to get to part B, the modification that's made, and I actually borrowed this. You can see that I have this heavily inspired by J.H. Franklin is the GitHub username. Because I wasn't actually sure what to do here. And it has this very cute trick that uses one of my favorite bqn idioms that basically it does a deduplication and stores your current list in the form of a the array equivalent of a hash map or the counter collection
在 Python 中，你跟踪值的数量和该值出现的次数，所以每次它就像一个直方图运算符，完全正确，而且所以这个，双字符……因为我没解释就跳过了，对于听众来说……如果你有索引的逆运算，那是 BQN 的一个惯用语，基本上可以为你提供数字列表的直方图，所以索引，如果你基本上在简单的情况下，0 和 1，它会给你对应于 1 的索引。所以例如，如果我有序列，BQN 是一种从 0 开始索引的语言。所以如果你有 1 0 1 0 1，并且你执行索引，也就是斜杠，它会给你返回 0、2 和 4，因为
in python where you keep track of the number of values and the number of times that value shows up and so every single time it's like a histogram operator exactly exactly and and so this the the two characters uh because i skated over it without explaining for the listener uh if you have the inverse of indices that is a bqn idiom for basically giving you the histogram of a list of numbers so indices if you're given basically in the simple case, zeros and ones, it'll give you the indices that correspond to the ones. So for instance, if I have the sequence and BQN is a zero index language. So if you have one zero one zero one, and you perform indices, which is just a slash on that, it'll give you back zero, two, and four, because
那些是对应于 1 的索引。然而，那是索引的子集。从技术上讲，它会给你每个索引的两个或三个，或者通常是每个索引的 n 个，其中 n 是对应于该索引的数字，所以如果我把我的序列从 10101 改为 10203，我会得到 022444，如果这有意义的话，好的，好的，所以有些人实际上把索引称为复制，因为你可以认为不是取对应于 1 的索引，而是你把索引复制 n 次，对应于该索引的 n，对吧？所以……所以这现在让我想到了 Advent of Code 的磁盘碎片整理那一天，输入就像一个 RLE 字符串，听起来非常类似于索引可能做的事情，所以事实上，我不记得那个名字了，但几乎可以肯定那就是我做的，我想我用了索引或复制器、拷贝器，无论你想怎么称呼它
those are the indices that correspond to ones. However, that's the subset of what indices is. Technically, it will give you two of every index or three of every index, or in general, n of every index, where n is the number that corresponds to that index so if i changed my sequence from 10101 to 10203 i'd get 022444 if that makes sense okay okay so some people refer to indices actually as copy because you you can think of instead of taking the indices that correspond to ones you're copying the indexes n times for the n that corresponds to that index right so the oak so this is now making me think of the the disk defragmenting day for event of code which was like the input was like an rle string sounds very similar to to kind of what indexes might might do so in fact i can't remember the name of that but almost uh surely that is what i did i think i used a indices or replicator copier whatever you want to call it
来创建那个，如果你基本上可以取那个，它会自动生成……我想它有点棘手，因为我错误地解决了那个问题，我没意识到你可以有超过一位数的数字，这完全破坏了……就像你可以有一个两位数的数字，这意味着你不能只看单个的东西……所以现在我已经解释了索引的作用，索引的逆运算，或者技术上 undo 是 BQN 中的运算符，它的技术名称，它会取一个数字列表。它技术上为这个惯用语做了一个小技巧，它先排序。然后它给你那个会给你那个数字列表的所谓掩码，所以如果我有数字列表 0 2 2 4 4 4，想象一下那些可以重新排列，所以它是索引的逆运算
to create that if you're if you can basically take that it'll auto generate um i think it's a little bit trickier because i solved that problem incorrectly i i didn't realize you could have more than a single digit number and that totally breaks right like you can you can have a two digit number which means you can't just look at the individual things um and so now that i've explained what indices does, indices inverse, or technically undo is the operator in BQN, its technical name, it will take a list of numbers. It technically does a little trick for this idiom, and it sorts it first. And then it gives you the quote unquote mask that would give you that list of numbers so if if i have the list of numbers zero two two four four four and imagine that those could be rearranged so it's the inverse of
，所以它给你 1 0 2 0 3，完全正确，是的，就像……就在那里，这可能是我们失去了一些听众，但这在屏幕上是两个字符，在索引内部，基本上我们……我喜欢认为它 90% 的时间只是布尔掩码版本，它是你过滤器的等效物，而且实际上技术上我想我完全搞砸了对这个的解释。单子版本是我们一直在谈论的那个，你只是把它应用于数字列表，然后你可以反转它来得到直方图，这基本上是这个问题开始的方式。所以这一切都是为了建立这样一个事实，即虽然当我只是解决 A 部分时，你可以只处理你的架构，稍微调整一下解决方案，添加这个步骤函数，这是你每次执行 blink 函数和初始输入时的样板。你基本上需要，像，直方图化每次迭代。然后这就是为什么对于 A 部分和 B 部分现在你有了这个 last，因为你需要得到这些的计数。等等，等一下。
indices so it gives you one zero two zero three exactly which is yeah like right there that is probably we lost a few listeners but like this is two characters on screen and inside basically indices like we have i like to think of it 90 of the time as just the boolean mask version it's it's it's your equivalent of a filter and actually technically i think i'm i've totally messed up my explanation of this. The monadic version is the one that we've been talking about where you just apply it to a list of numbers, and then you can invert it to get the histogram, which is basically how this problem starts out. So this is all building up to the fact that whereas for when I was just solving part A, you can just work on yourarchitect the solution a little bit, add this step function that is this boilerplate of every single time you perform the blink function and on the initial input. You basically need to, like, histogramize each iteration. And then that's why for part A and part B now you have this last because you're needing to get the counts of these. Actually, wait a second.
那怎么……那实际上说不通，对吧？因为你需要把它们相乘才能在最后得到总和。那是……B 部分，它实际上要求什么？它要求的是。是的。这是第 11 天。
How does that? That actually doesn't make sense, right? Because you need to multiply them in order to get the total sums at the end of the day. Is that what? Did part B, what did it actually ask for? What it's asking for. Yeah. This is day 11.
B 部分。或者更确切地说。当 Ben 和我都在读……哦，它要求的是序列的长度。好的。是的，是的。所以这就是为什么它得到 last，因为我本来想说如果这应该是每个数字的总和，那将是错误的，但它正在做的是得到计数，这在技术上是这些键值对中的值，然后只是把计数加起来，这然后是正确的，所以……总之，我不确定，而且还有……
Part B. Or rather. As Ben and I are both reading the. Oh, it's asking for the length of the sequence. Okay. Yeah, yeah. So that's why it's getting the last because i was like i was going to say if this was supposed to be the sum of each of the numbers this would be wrong uh but what it's doing is it's getting the counts which is technically the value in these key value pairs and then just summing up the counts uh which then it is correct so uh anyways i'm not sure and then also too like
这是……我不会讲这个，但在步骤函数中，我把它 tacit 化了，也就是我让整个表达式变得 tacit，这可能损害了它的可读性，因为有很多……我不想说它是行噪声，但对于不习惯 BQN 的人来说，这是不可读的。我可以在里面看到一些东西。我可以看到一个归约。我可以看到一些文本。我可以看到一些加法。
this is i'm not going to walk through this but in the step function i tacitized aka like i made the whole expression tacit probably to the it harmed the readability of this because there's a there's a lot a little bit i don't want say line noise, but to someone who's not used to BQN, this is not readable. I can see a few things in there. I can see a reduction. I can see some text. I can see some ads.
所以，你知道，它绝对是可识别的，但我认为这是你视频中函数最终的样子，我想我们可以这么说。好吧，我的意思是，有时我会让某事变得 tacit，然后事后觉得，啊，这并没有更可读。但我经历了让它 tacit 的过程，所以我就会把它留在那里。当然，是的。
So, you know, it's definitely recognizable, but it's typical as to what the functions end up like in your videos, I think we could say. Well, I mean, sometimes I'll make something tacit and then after the fact be like, ah, this is not more readable. But I went through the process of making it tacit, so I'll just leave it there. Sure, yeah.
我的意思是，这是 Advent of Code，不是生产系统，对吧？所以我不知道。听完之后你有什么想法？这是……这很有趣，你知道，因为它非常不同。所以 A 部分，你知道，Advent of Code 问题是这样设置的。以便在 A 部分，你可以实现朴素的解决方案，对吧？而朴素的解决方案只是将自动机函数应用于每个单元格
I mean, it's advent of code, not production system stuff, right? So I'm not sure. What are your thoughts after having been walked through? Is this... It's interesting, you know, because it's very different. So part A, you know, Avent of Code problems are set up like this. So that in part A, you can implement the naive solution, right? And the naive solution is just to apply the automaton function to every cell
并只是扩展数组，25 步之后，你计算你有多少个。而那，我想最初就是你做的，也是我在 Python 中做的，可能每个人都做了。但随后 B 部分要求你，而且你知道这里有一种情况，如果 B 部分只是一行代码，我们也许应该害怕，是的，因为就像我做了这个，我没有为 B 部分做好成功的准备，是的，而且 B 部分，你知道，如果你用朴素的解决方案，你会等上几年甚至几个世纪，即使你有所需的内存量，所以你在 BQN 中对 B 部分的方法与我对 B 部分的方法非常不同，我不想……我不知道 Eric 的目标是什么，但我怀疑 Eric 希望引导人们走向的方法是动态规划方法，记忆化方法。而且看到这个问题可以通过 BQN 以这种不同的方式被攻击，通过改变输出的表示，这很有趣，我的意思是这在 Python 中也会非常容易做到
and just expand the array, and 25 steps later, you count how many you've got. And that, I think, is originally what you did and what I did in Python and what probably everyone did. But then part b requires you and you know there's a sort of thing here where if if part b is just a one-liner we perhaps we should be afraid yes because because it's like i did this i did not set myself up for success for part b yeah and part b you know you'd be waiting years if not centuries with a naive solution um even if you had the amount of memory required so your approach to part b in bqn was very different to my approach to part b and i don't want i don't know what Eric was going for, but I suspect the approach Eric was hoping to lead people towards was the dynamic programming approach, the memoization approach. And it's interesting to see that this one was attackable by BQN in this different way, by changing the representation of the output right i mean this it would have been
因为计数器集合就像拼写这里构建的大部分内容的六字符方式，好的，好的，好吧，我在 Python 中做的方法是添加一个记忆化装饰器，是的，生成石头扩展的函数。而且奇怪的是，这实际上也是我最初的想法，即缓存和记忆化是 B 部分的解决方案。而且我实际上去了……有一个 BQN 排行榜，人们可以提交他们的 GitHub 仓库，它会跟踪谁在做这些，所以你可以很容易地去看看其他人的
really easy to do this in python as well because the counter collection is like a six character way to spell a lot of what was built out here okay okay well how i did it in python was to add uh a memorization decorator yeah the function that generates the stone expansion. And curiously, that was actually my initial thought as well, is that caching and memorization is the solution to Part B. And I actually went and there is a BQN leaderboard of sorts that folks that want then can submit their you know github repo and it tracks who's doing them so you can go and take a look very easily at other folks
解决方案以获取灵感，我会说 80/20，80% 的人利用了记忆化，使用了一些我根本不知道存在的东西。有一个系统哈希映射，如果你需要的话可以伸手去拿。它非常，我会说，非数组惯用语，因为你在使用，更新像哈希映射和这种对象上的方法。所以你基本上可以做你痛苦地做的事情。就像在 BQN 中没有你可以调用的装饰器说，哦，对了，它记忆化了，你必须去手动做，哦，我已经有了一个预先计算的东西的哈希映射，每当我看到里面有东西时，C++ 中也没有自动记忆化，我想我看到一些人，比如 Sy 或 Tristan，一直在 Blue Sky 上发布他们的解决方案。
solutions uh for inspiration and i would say it was 80 20 uh 80 being folks that were making use of memoization using something i had no idea existed There's a system hash map that you can reach for if you need it. It's very, I would say, un-array idiomatic in that you're using, updating like a hash map and methods on this kind of object. And so you can basically do what you did painfully. Like there's no decorator you can call in P qn like oh right it memoizes you have to go and manually do the oh i've got a a hash map of already pre-calculated stuff and whenever i see that something's in there there's no automatic memoization in c++ either i think i saw some folks like um sy or tristan have been have been have been putting out their solutions on Blue Sky.
对于像第 7 天这样记忆化很重要，或者至少是做第 2 天的一种明显方式的日子，我们可能会说。是的。是的，他们不得不引入像哈希映射之类的东西。是的，完全正确。或者无序映射，无论它可能是什么。所以这很有趣。你说像这些日子中的一些要求你在 BQN 中做一些棘手的事情。
And for the days like day seven, where memorization was important, or at least a sort of obvious way to do day two, we might say. Yeah. Yes, they've had to pull in things like hash maps and things. Yeah, exactly. Or unordered map, whatever it might be. So it's interesting. You said like some of these days require you to do things in BQN which are tricky.
在 C++ 中也是如此。这就是为什么我得出了……就像我们在对话开始时所说的，这就是为什么我得出了这样一个想法，即首先如果你在做 AOC，根本就没有作弊，没有……你知道，任何通往解决方案的路径都是有效的，这里没有把关，没有你必须是纯粹主义者，用这种语言做，那种语言，无论如何，在我看来，任何通往解决方案的路径都是有效的，我的意思是如果你在查找别人的解决方案，你并没有在学习，除非你可能在那种情况下也在学习，对吧？就像如果你只是想不出解决像 B 部分的方法
And also in C++. Which is why I've come to the, like we said at the beginning of the conversation, which is why I've come to the idea that to begin with if you're doing aoc at all there is there is no there is no cheating there is no like you know like any route to the solution is valid there's no there's no gatekeeping here there's no you must be a purist do it in this language this language whatever in my view any route to a solution is valid i mean you're not learning if you're looking up someone else's solution except that you might be learning even in that case right like if you if you just can't think of a way how to solve like a part b
然后你查找别人的解决方案，你从中学习，那也是有效的，当你坐下来做 BQN 时，你觉得还有其他日子你做了……还有另一天你做了一个……有一个循环，你实际上在 BQN 中写了一个循环，一个 while 循环，而且我看着那个代码，我在想那看起来不像惯用的 BQN，那不是我通常在 Connor 的视频中看到的那种东西，所以你知道，而且我们不是在挑剔 BQN，因为我认为每种语言都是一样的，就像在 C++ 中处理正则表达式也很痛苦。或者，你知道，我们可以随机挑选几天说这在某种语言中很容易，这在另一种语言中很难。所以这个观察背后的问题是，在你看来，BQN 是为了什么？它擅长什么？
and you look up someone else's solution you learn from it that's valid too when you sit down and do bqn do you feel there are other days where you did there's no there was another day where you did a there was a loop you actually wrote a loop in bqn a while loop and uh i'm looking at that code and i'm thinking that doesn't look like idiomatic bqn that's not the kind of thing i normally see on connor's videos so you know and that's that we could we're not picking on bqn here because it's the same i think for every language like like dealing with regular expressions in C++ is painful too. Or, you know, we could pick random days and say this is really easy in this language, this is hard in this other language. So the question behind this observation is like, what is BQN for, in your opinion? What is it good at?
它解决得好吗？它的典型应用是什么？请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及 GitHub 讨论的链接
What does it solve well? And what is its typical application? Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion
你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反括号。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在这里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢您的收听。希望您喜欢这期节目，祝您有愉快的一天。我是反括号。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。